good morning believe nation today's
message is think big over to you Vince
McMahon my dad was talking about selling
out and that frightened me because I
didn't know if I'd be a part or not and
so I knew there was just some way I had
to get my hands on this company in front
of his father and a group of doubting
investors Vince works out a series of
convoluted business deals somehow it
works Vince and Linda McMahon now on
Vince seniors company McMahon's vision
is to create a truly worldwide Pro
Wrestling franchise I knew my dad
wouldn't really sold me the business had
he known what I was going to do and the
vision of an international point of view
of her business was nothing new I mean I
wanted to do that from day one my dad
thought it was nuts and he was right
really but I didn't know all those nuts
and then we just went ahead about doing
it Vince McMahon working with his wife
Linda begins building a national and
international brand for wrestling
the WWF in the process he will nearly
decimate the existing wrestling
establishment in a controversial
offensive worthy of the military
commander he bring in his best wrestlers
into an era he was trying to capture
he'd buy time and show videotapes of
their matches last weekend come to the
arena come to the Coliseum the Saturday
you'll see Antonino Rocca who soever he
was pushing and he would take one at a
time it was a blitzkrieg my dad would
get these phone calls from his cronies
you know who had these little fiefdom
events you know what's your kid Don he's
coming into my territory he's gonna wind
up dead you know I'm gonna crush him
like a grape that means I'm gonna have
to come to New York and my dad was very
very concerned and once he saw that we
were succeeding in and I had to head
competition with them now my dad began
to
I think maybe this is going to work
after all one promoter after another
promoter after another promoter and they
didn't fight back and they didn't
coalesce and they didn't come together
they watched and threw up their hands
and ran like the dickens not knowing he
had a no money and B they could have won
and held their position thank you guys
so much for watching the question of the
day today is I want to know what your
big vision is when nobody else is around
when when you don't have any inhibitions
when you think you can do big bold
things what is that big vision that you
want to accomplish for yourself your
business leaving the comments below
I'm gonna join in the discussion I also
want to give a quick shout out to
michael wolfmann from ponte vedra
fitness.com thank you so much you're
picking up a cup of my book your one
word it really really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso hey
believe nation if you want some more
motivation on thinking big stay tuned
for some special bonus clips some of
y'all have a habit of dreaming with in
your bank account some of your thoughts
and visions are so big and so outlandish
and so powerful and amazing you'll end
up talking yourself out of that dream
from saying I can't afford that well
guess what there's a lot of [ __ ] I can't
afford there's a lot of visions and
dreams that I still can't afford I've
always always had this idea that one day
I'm gonna meet a multi-billionaire and
with this multi-billionaire we're gonna
become the best of friends
and he's gonna say to me Tyrese I got
all the money in the world but I don't
have your visions or your ideas and I'll
say to him I got you I'm not gonna lie
to you I'm not gonna waste your time I
got big visions and ideas I can't afford
them all but it's not gonna stop me from
having these visions and ideas I came
here to remind you that when people
laugh if your visions and ideas it's
only because they don't have their own
visions and ideas around what they're
supposed to do with their life or their
careers people that don't have any
dreams for themselves they tend to be
dream killers people that don't have
their own visions they become vision
killers they want nothing more than to
talk you out of your own visions they
don't have dreams for themselves they
don't have any hopes they're hopeless
they're uninspired unmotivated
they have no dreams they have nothing
that they're ambitious about but I want
to remind you to continue to dream and
dream big I have a habit of dreaming
with my eyes open
I get very inspired by the things I see
I'm inspired by architecture I'm
inspired by photography I'm inspired by
ideas I'm inspired by the idea that
someone can have a vision and if that
vision had stayed in their mind they
would have robbed the world of the
opportunity to experience that vision
I mean think about this as big as this
is the fact that it's in the middle of
the street if they had kept this idea
inside their minds I wouldn't be here to
look at it or experience it this is the
power of visions and ideas right here
you see it this is the power of not
allowing anyone to laugh at you when you
say I want to build something a
sculpture that can go in the middle of
the street and it can be an iconic
sculpture that will last forever long
after I'm dead and gone this could be a
sculpture that can stand in the middle
of a street here in the streets of Paris
and if this person who built this would
have allowed people to talk to him out
of their dreams and their visions it
wouldn't be here for us to see or
experience my voice is gone we had a
sold-out show here in Paris I just
wanted to remind you to dream and dream
big and understand that your family and
friends and loved ones in most cases
boyfriends/girlfriends
they will be the first to try and talk
you out of your dreams your visions and
ideas as to what you're supposed to do
with your life they will say who wants
you when you've already had two or three
kids who wants you when you put on all
that weight who wants you when you're
looking like this and been through this
and been through that nobody's
interested in you nobody's checking for
you they'll laugh at you they'll call
you names because they have no dreams
they have no hunger for success
they don't have an appetite
they don't want it I want to win so bad
my hunger and appetite for success is
intimidating it scares the [ __ ] out of
people I come up with new visions and
ideas every single day and people around
me say slow down stop you're doing too
much your appetite is too big I can't
help myself
I want to build I want to win I'm a
billionaire I was a I was a change air I
was a doll in air I was a thousand-aire
I am a millionaire there's only one step
left the billion I don't think I'll see
a trillion but I know I'll see a billion
I believe it I believe it and there's no
one in the world that can talk me out of
that feeling
sending my love all the way from Paris
if you make it to the end of this video
I want you to write only those that can
see the invisible can do the impossible
you have to be able to see what doesn't
exist in order to be able to pull off or
achieve what in most people's mind seems
to be impossible only those that can see
the invisible being able to see what's
not there what is your vision what is
your idea what was that god-sent dream
only those that can see the invisible
can do what seems to be impossible
have to be relentless you have to never
let off the gas never stop never quit
never allow anyone to talk you out of
the dream division and ideas that God
has sent you as a compound in Mountain
View California internet billionaire
Naveen Jain is hatching a plan that
could make him the world's first
trillionaire movie
get to see my friend so Devine the team
is working hard as it usually is for
summer so we're gonna land on the moon
somewhere around here close to where the
Apollo spacecraft landed at the equator
how did you pick that area
well it's first of all it's on the near
side so it's easily accessible from
Earth it's an area the dark area are
actually regions of lava Plains so
they're not mountainous not so long ago
it was the Soviet and America's super
powers that were locked in a race to
land on the moon
now it's Bob and Naveen who are leading
the competition to mine precious metals
from its surface are we still on track
to land on the moon by 2015 we're still
on track today initially we thought the
mission was going to cost us about
hundred million dollars do you think we
can bring the cost down to say fifty to
sixty million dollars yeah even less
yeah I think the first mission will be
under 50 and subsequent missions maybe
under 40
then would we be able to tell your honey
that I want to take you to the moon ten
years ten years not only will it be a
honeymoon but I can taking my honey to
the moon and I think that'll be the
killer if you can do that that's real
business if we can go to the moon for
fifty million dollars and the cost comes
to opportuni and we're able to bring
back that things were 500 billion
dollars I don't care what anybody says
that's a great business somebody is
going to create a trillion dollar
industry in space and we sure hope it's
not see when you tell somebody what
you're doing and they don't think is a
crazy idea then you're thinking too
small so when you walk up to a party and
people say what do you do well I mind
the moon well that's that's crazy
well I'm thinking big